Okay, so good morning.
Um,
today we start the Vikings.
We will do it over two classes.
Um. And the Vikings
are extremely interesting.
And I believe that they are one of the
most under-appreciated and misunderstood
European cultures.
In the Western tradition
uh, there are two main pillars, the
Greco-Romans and the Judeo-Christians.
Um, the four traditions uh, the Greeks,
the Romans, the Jews, the Christians
um, have been overstudied
uh, and over-appreciated. I would argue
that the Vikings are very important and
should be part of these four pillars. I
think there should be five pillars and I
think um, that over next few decades
people will, scholars will
slowly reveal to us the importance of
Viking culture to to development of
Western civilization. So that's my
argument to you over next two classes,
that the Vikings are
extremely influential.
And um, so today I'll do an overview of
Viking history and influence. And in
next class I'll focus more on the
cultural system of the Vikings, what
they believed
um, and how they understood the world.
Okay.
So let's do a brief historical overview.
So the Viking age is what scholars term
the period from the year 793 to 1066. 79
is uh, when there was the first
recorded, written down um,
incident of a Viking raid on a monastery
in Europe. And this is really the first
uh, one of the first written records of
the Vikings.
The Vikings were always there, actually,
and there was some interaction between
the Vikings and the rest of Europe. For
example, Vikings did serve as
mercenaries in the Roman Empire.
Okay, so there was always a bit of
interaction, but
for the most part,
the Vikings were an isolated culture.
1066, the year that the Viking Age is
supposedly to have ended, is the year of
the Battle of Hastings. That is when
Normandy, the Normans, who lived in
France, they crossed English Channel and
conquered England. And this is the last
time that England would be conquered.
And this would mark the end of the
Viking Age because it really marked the
assimilation or integration of Viking
culture into the broader European
framework. Okay? So, that's what
scholars mean by the Viking Age.
All right. So, the Vikings
are from the three countries today we
call Denmark,
Norway, and Sweden. Okay? Collectively,
they are known as the Scandinavian
countries.
What's interesting about this area is
the geography. This is a
topography, okay? Red means high
altitude high altitude. Blue means low
altitude, so by the sea. As you can see
from the topography,
um
the Scandinavian area is extremely
diverse.
And as a result,
the region historically has been very
poor, isolated,
um
and diverse. Okay? So,
so this area for the longest time had
tremendous diversity in terms of culture
and politics. You had kings, you had
tribal chieftains, and then you had
different systems as as well.
Okay?
Um
during the Viking Age, what we need to
keep in mind is this is a period in
history when Europe was being invaded or
attacked or pillaged from everyone
basically, okay? So, the three main
invaders
are the Vikings who come in from the
north. But, then you have people called
the Magyars who are the modern day
Hungarians coming in from the east. From
the south comes the Arabs.
Okay, next week we will do the Arabs.
The Magyars, just just that you know who
the Magyars are, they are just the most
recent iteration of the
Proto-Indo-Europeans,
the Yamnaya.
Remember last semester we discussed
that 3 to 4,000 years ago Old Europe who
are mainly
who are which was mainly an agricultural
society, they were eventually invaded
and conquered by the
Proto-Indo-Europeans,
the Yamnaya, who lived in the steppes.
Uh these are pastoral nomads.
And as a as a result, they brought their
culture to them. So, the Magyars are
just the most recent iteration of this
culture, okay? Same as the Huns, same as
the Goths, same as the Germanic people.
Um
what's interesting about the Magyars is
that they are mainly a land people,
meaning they ride horses into battle.
And uh for and during the Viking Age,
they were extremely successful pene-
penetrating into many parts
of Europe before they are eventually
defeated and they're integrated into the
the main European culture mainly by you
guys remember?
Making into Christians, right?
That that's how you assimilate people in
Europe by turning them into Christians.
And because
this is the Western Europe, a lot of
them become Catholic. But some also
become
Orthodox as well.
The Vikings are a very different culture
because they attacked Europe not by
land, not with cavalry and horses, but
by sea and rivers. Okay, this is a
maritime people.
And what's really interesting about the
Vikings is how far they extend across
the world. Okay? So, the first the first
sort of encounter is when the Vikings
start to raid and pillage Europe,
okay? Northern and Central Europe.
But over time, what they will do is they
will extend over to the east as well
where they will found two major
settlements. The first is Kiev
in modern-day Ukraine
as well as Novgorod. Okay? So, they are
going going into the Dnieper as well as
the Volga. Why are they here? There's
some pillaging, but mainly it's for
trade purposes because if you look at
where they are in Kiev and Novgorod, it
gives it gives them access to three
major centers of global wealth. The
first, of course, is the Byzantine
Byzantine Empire in Constantinople,
which we
studied.
Then there is something called the
Abbasid Caliphate, which is the Islamic
Empire in Baghdad.
And the third, of course, is the Silk
Road, right? Which gives them access to
China.
So, in other words, the Vikings
encountered every major culture in the
world at this time through their trade
routes.
And then, what they will also do is go
west
to found colonies. They will make
settlements in Iceland, in Greenland,
and in modern-day
uh Canada. Uh the settlement's called
Vinland. Uh and it's in modern-day
Newfoundland, okay?
So, Iceland is still with us today.
And Iceland is very interesting uh for
three reasons.
The first reason is, even though in this
class I keep on saying there's no such
thing as cultural and genetic purity,
that that the the Icelanders come pretty
close, okay? There's about 300 330,000
people who live in Iceland today, and
they're all related to each other. And
that's because for the longest time
Iceland
uh has been isolated from the rest of
the world. And it it has always been
extremely peaceful, egalitarian, and
progressive society.
They had the world's first
uh concept of parliament called the
Althing. And that's where every
um citizen would come together once a
year to discuss the major political
events um
of of Iceland.
So, in other words, they really built
they really built the cornerstone of
modern European democracy. But not only
that, but a lot of the stories, the
mythology of the Vikings,
were
reconceptualized and written down in
Iceland.
And these sagas, they're called sagas,
okay, would become the foundation of
modern European literature.
So, the cultural contribution of Iceland
and the
uh wider Viking culture to the European
cultural framework, it cannot be
um overstated, okay?
Also, they will make their way to the
British Isles.
Um they will have made major encounters
with the
uh British people as well as Irish
people. They will found a new city in
Ireland called Dublin, which as you know
is the modern-day capital of
of Ireland.
Okay? And as And what they will also do
is they will settle down in Normandy.
And the reason why is
they keep on attacking northern Europe,
mainly the Carolingian Empire. Um and
Charles the Simple, the king um of
Carolingian Empire, he will defeat them
in a battle.
And then he will give them land
in Normandy. So, Normandy means land of
the Norse people.
And then from Normandy, as I mentioned,
they will cross the English Channel and
conquer England in the year 1066 at the
Battle of Hastings.
So,
if you look at this map, what you will
discover is
the Vikings
either founded or influenced four major
European civilizations. They are
Germany,
France, Britain, and Russia.
Now, what's interesting is that for the
past 500 years, these four
nations were the dominant militaries in
the world.
And not only that, but they were the
dominant civilized civilizations
in the world. We think of modern Western
civilization, really we we really mean
these four nations: Britain,
France, Germany,
and Russia. That's where
the very best literature,
philosophy, and art uh comes from. And
what I will show you next class, not
this class, but what I'll show you next
class is this is not just a historical
coincidence. There are reasons and
factors that would uh that will help us
better explain why this happened.
Okay?
Um this is the
um settlement in Newfoundland.
Okay? So, this was actually the first
European settlement in the New World,
North America, and this is 500 years at
least 500 years before Christopher
Columbus.
Um this is a map that shows the Viking
expansion over time, okay? So, as you
can see from this map, they they they
basically expand outwards. And as they
gather more information about the world,
they continue to expand. Okay? So, what
is the culture, what is the mentality of
the worldview that drives this
aggressive expansion?
What is the Viking worldview? And this
is something that I will introduce this
class, but explain
uh more in detail next class.
Um
So, today when we think of the Vikings,
we just think of raiders and pillagers.
But what's important for us to remember
is that the larger Viking culture, most
people did not do that. Most people when
they engage with the uh European world,
it was mo- mainly through trade, okay?
The vast majority was through trade. And
they were and they were and then you
have people, Vikings, who um join the
European world as mercenaries because
they were very good fighters. And then
you went up you had a small minority
who uh were raiders and pillagers. But
because they were so violent, they
captured the imagination
of the Europeans and they inform um how
we today see the Vikings.
Um this is a map of the Viking expansion
and the yellow
are
written records,
documented Viking raids in Europe. And
as you can see, there's a lot of them,
okay? They're mainly by the coast,
they're mainly by rivers because again,
the Vikings raided mainly by using their
longships, their ships.
Um they mainly raided monasteries.
And uh to better understand monasteries,
what they were, imagine that they are
the equivalent of universities. They're
basically the medieval equivalent of
universities. These are places where
monks spent most of the time um
worshipping God by celebrating
his literary works, mainly the Bible.
Okay?
Um
The So, the the monasteries were built
during something called the Carolingian
Renaissance and this marked the
beginning of the Holy Roman Empire.
During this time, there's a major major
focus The major cultural focus was on
producing books. Our modern conception
of the book actually comes from this
period. They took all this sort of
diverse innovation such as printing,
uh book making,
uh fonts, ink, and combined with a
system of bookbinding that we still use
today.
Okay? So, they mainly focus on uh
religious classics like the Bible, okay?
And what they would do is they would
illustrate them. It would take about 20
to 30 years for an individual monk to
create one of of these books. So, it was
it was a
uh it was an artwork, basically.
Um during this time, they experiment
with they experiment with different
fonts. If you go to your computer and
you ask Microsoft Word what kind of font
you want to use, like Corillian or
others, all of these fonts were actually
invented during this time.
Okay?
Uh they also invented bookbinding at
this time as as well.
And what they would do
um to mark their cultural achievement is
they would make covers of gold and
jewels, diamonds, sapphires, rubies
um as a book cover.
All right? So, these were extremely
valuable, unique artwork.
This is another book cover.
Okay? Extremely gorgeous. Again, they
would spend a lot of resources, 20 to 30
years, in crafting each of these books.
And that's why the Vikings raided them,
because the Vikings knew through the
trade networks that the monasteries had
this concentration of wealth in them.
There was a lot of gold and silver and
jewelry in monasteries. And in the
Viking culture,
um these precious metals was were a
status symbol. They wanted them, okay?
But you can imagine what the Vikings
did, because the Vikings were a pagan
non-literate people. They didn't
understand books, they didn't have no
use for books. So, they they would come
in
and they would take these
books, the Bible, rip out the pages, and
keep the gold, and then leave. Okay? So,
you're a monk, and you see this, right?
And it's the equivalent of having your
child killed before you.
It was extremely traumatic for them.
And again, the monks are literate
people. So, they had absolutely nothing
nice to say about the Vikings. In fact,
they thought that the Vikings were
basically the equivalent of Satan. Okay?
And And that's And that's why we have
such a negative understanding of the
Vikings, mainly through these raids,
which again, were only a minority of
Viking activity
during this time.
Um
gradually, over time, what would happen
is that as the Vikings made more wealth
from monasteries, word would spread back
to
the larger Viking culture, and more and
more people would partake in these
raids, until eventually, they developed
the skill, the systems, and the
technology to sack even cities like
Paris, which was a heavily fortified
city.
Okay? And they would do this multiple
times
during the Viking Age.
So,
what's important for us to understand is
that this these Viking raids would drive
population growth
in Scandinavia, and then this would
drive further
Viking expansion throughout the world.
Okay? So, it was a cycle.
Um let's look at
some cultural aspects of the Vikings.
So, this is These are pictures of
high-status, meaning basically warriors
um in the
uh Scandinavian culture.
And these This is a picture of these
Vikings uh in the East. They are called
the Rus.
Okay? The Rus. And the Rus would would
then would would become Russia. Okay?
So, Russia, the country, would borrow
its name from the the Vikings, Rus.
So, some things some things to
I will point out about
these visuals.
Look at the helmets, okay? The Vikings
the popular
depiction of the Vikings is
they had helmets of horns, right? Have
you seen movies? They did not have
horns, guys. Because horns are extremely
unpragmatic impractical, okay?
You might get stuck on on your boat or
or your enemy could yank it off you,
okay? So, these were extremely practical
and utilitarian people. They were not
that wealthy. They had to be very
careful and conscious about everything
they did. Okay? So, that's the first
thing. Second thing is that you will see
major cultural differences between
Western Vikings and Eastern Vikings. And
the reason why is as the Vikings are
interacting with different cultures,
they're also assimilating themselves
into different cultures. They're
intermarrying, they're adopting local
languages and local cultures, and
they're also lending their own culture
to these cultures, okay? So, history is
a continuous process of cultural
integration.
All right? It's dynamic process. It
never really ends.
Okay?
And the third thing we need we need to
appreciate is
these are a poor people.
And as such, they're extremely
egalitarian.
Even though this these are high-status
people, they're not that different from
the majority of Vikings who are
independent farmers, basically.
Okay?
This is where they usually live. This is
called a longhouse.
All right? And so, because the weather
in Scandinavia is very cold for most of
the year, these are a very social
people. They live together. They spend
most of the time together.
Okay? So, this is a picture of a Viking
hall.
Um most of the time the Vikings are
together
and they're usually drinking
and they're telling stories to each
other.
Okay?
And so, they're they're very much
focused on the oral tradition.
Let's look very quickly at their
longships, which is the dominant uh
maritime technology of the day. Okay?
These are not that big, but they're but
they are purposely designed
to be small so that they have
flexibility
um and maneuverability.
Okay?
Um
so, this this is what we think the ships
look like.
And this is what they really look like.
Um so, some points we need to know about
the ships is
first of all, from these ships you can
see that there's really no hierarchy in
place. We don't know who the captain is.
There's a captain, but he's really not
that different from the others. Okay?
So, the Viking culture is extremely
egalitarian, which is important if you
want um cohesion on the battlefield.
These the Vikings raided mainly for
gold, but also for slaves. Okay? They're
so, they're trading with the wider
world, the Arabs, the Byzantines, uh the
Chinese. Um they're what they were
trading were slaves in exchange for
silver, which is very important for
their culture.
Okay? So, they were So, they these were
slavers.
Um the other thing to know about these
ships is they're not that big. And the
reason why is they're usually traversing
rivers. When you when you when you're
traversing rivers, you need to be
flexible. So, some sometimes you might
hit some rocks. Well, then what you have
to do is move that ship out of those
rocks and go somewhere else, okay?
All right. So,
that's the idea of the longship. And
again, this was the dominant maritime
technology of that time. The Europeans
actually I had actually no way to
counter this.
Okay. Um also, what's important for us
to understand is the Vikings had also
many different designs.
So,
the thing about the Viking ships is
they're extremely lean and mean. They're
extremely efficient. You know, the only
way you can achieve this efficiency is
through constant innovation. So, the
Vikings are constantly always thinking
about how to better improve their ships.
Um the last thing I will mention is the
idea of the Viking
funeral.
Now, in cultures that we've studied,
there's always a spectacle
that is the highlight of this culture.
So,
uh the Romans they had something called
a triumph,
which was a military parade to celebrate
a general's military victories overseas.
It was It was like the
um biggest event in uh uh in the life of
a Roman, okay? So, this would be the
equivalent of the Nobel Prize today.
The Greeks had as equivalent of the
triumph theater, right?
Um every Greek wanted to be a
playwright.
That was the highlight of Athenian
cultural life.
What's interesting for us is that for
the Vikings, the spectacle that they
they cared the most about was a funeral,
okay? Obviously, not everyone would get
an elaborate funeral.
Only the chieftains or the great
warriors would get an elaborate funeral.
But these funerals would take 10 days
and it would be very expensive.
Basically, the entire savings of this
great warrior would be invested in the
funeral.
Um there'd be a lot of sacrifices,
mainly horse and animals. Humans would
be sacrificed as well.
And the warrior, the king, would be
buried with his ship.
All right?
So, next class, what I will do is go
into detail
about these funerals, explain to you why
they happened, and the cultural
significance.
All right?
Okay.
So, that's an overview of the Vikings.
What I will do now is um explain the
Vikings in the larger historical
framework that we've been studying this
semester. But before I do that, are
there any questions about the Vikings?
Yes.
Okay. So, that's the slave trade, right?
Okay.
So, the slave trade, it is just an
integral and interesting part of life in
Europe at this time.
Um the population was very limited
because Europe was a poor place, and
there was very few agricultural surplus.
Plus, there was always these wars to be
fought, okay? So, slavery was was this
very important. Um the people who really
drove the slave trade, um were the
Byzantines and the Arabs. And there's
always demand from
these two cultural centers for slaves
which the Vikings provided. Now, what's
interesting for us about the slave trade
is
the Arabs are Muslim
and the Byzantines are Christian.
And the consensus at the time is you
cannot enslave a fellow believer.
So, Arabs cannot enslave Muslims.
Christians cannot enslave fellow
Christians. That's why the Vikings were
so
that's why the Vikings found slave trade
so profitable because the Vikings were
pagans. So, in theory, they could be
sold to anyone.
Okay? So, the Vikings basically
enslaved other pagans and sold them to
both the Byzantines and and the Arabs.
Okay? And And look look um the slave
trade it it has been an integral part of
human reaction, human trade for most of
civilization.
Okay? Does that make sense? It's only
it's it's really only only until the
British Empire that we see a clampdown
and abolishment of the slave trade. But
And also guys, I mean, I hate to say
this, but slavery still happens. It just
happens secretly. We don't really pay
much attention to it, but it still
happens. All right?
Okay, great great question. Any more
questions be- before I I I continue?
I I think it's
just a small question, but I remember a
long time ago
this is probably like 20 years ago.
In Sweden, they discovered a few of the
Viking
graves from from from the funerals like
where the where the ships were
Yeah.
And at that time, the Swedish government
decided like this was too sacred. We're
not going to open up the We're going to
keep it a kind of basically a mystery.
That's right.
Since then, do you know if any
anything has changed? Has anyone opened
up these or
Yeah.
So, um
So, so question then is, um we found
in the like our colleagues have found a
lot of these ship burials, a lot of
graves.
And there's just a lot of them.
And uh we we've we've had a chance to
study a lot of these graves.
And here's some interesting
characteristics about these graves,
okay? The first thing is
these graves are unique onto themselves.
There doesn't seem to be a system of
burying someone.
Okay? So, you have these graves where
um maybe a woman is buried with a horse.
Then you have another grave where a
woman is buried with a ship.
That's the first really interesting
thing about these graves. Second thing
is
these graves seem to have a um
uh a record of of lineage. And And what
what what we mean by that is these
people are buried on top of their
ancestors. So, um
if if a woman is buried here, then maybe
her granddaughter would be buried on top
of her.
Okay? So, there seems to be a story
going on um in these burials.
Okay? Now, the third thing
about these graves uh that we've
discovered is that um
there there's been a lot of care and
attention paid to how someone was
buried.
Okay? Clearly, um someone put a lot
thought or or the culture has put a lot
of thought into how this person will be
remembered.
All right? And what I will show you uh
next class is
what's important is not the burial.
What's important is the funeral, the
process of the burial, and that's where
the culture expresses itself.
And what I will show you next class is
these burials
they're meant to send the dead into the
afterlife. Okay, and that's very
important. What's really important um
and why they have this pageantry or
ritual in the funeral process is
it's really about
um memorizing that person into the
larger culture. Making sure that
everyone remembers the contributions of
that person and having that person
contribute eternally into the overall
culture, okay? If that makes sense.
Right? But again, as as as you know,
most of these graves have not been dug
up. So, right now we are making some
rudimentary guesses based on the
available evidence.
Okay?
All right.
Any more questions before I continue?
Okay. So, so I I know this is a lot to
take in, but we are spending two classes
on this and hopefully uh this will make
more sense to you as we move along,
okay?
All right, good. So, let me um discuss
the larger historical framework that the
Vikings are in.
Okay.
So,
the major thesis of the semester
is the idea of the oceanic oceanic
currents of history.
And so, one pattern that we see in
history is
a culture, you know, what we'll call the
borderlands,
they're isolated from most of history,
okay?
They're not completely isolated, but
they're mainly isolated.
And then what happens is that an empire,
a major civilization, expands
so that it starts to interact with
uh this borderline culture.
And what will happen for this
interaction is the energy of the empire
will start to transfer to the
borderlands. The borderlands itself will
expand, okay? And until it it comes into
conflict with the empire. And when this
uh conflict happens
the borderlands might be assimilated
into the empire, it might be destroyed
by the empire, or it might become the
empire itself.
All right? So, that's the
uh major idea of this class. And we see
this throughout history.
Okay? So, think of um
the Greeks and the Persians.
Think of the Romans and the the
Carthaginians. Think of the Arabs and
the um
the Persians, okay? So, we see this
pattern
uh repeat itself throughout history.
What I want to do now is apply this idea
to the Vikings and explain how this
process works. Why does this work?
Well,
if you think about it, an empire and
what what I mean empire I just mean
large civilization.
Um an empire and a
borderland culture
they are almost
um
complete opposites of each other.
Their advantages
um mirror the the the the the they
compensate for each other's advantage
and disadvantages.
So, for an empire, an empire usually
usually has three major advantages. They
are mass,
organization,
and depth.
Okay?
Some historians use the word strategic
depth, okay?
All right. So, what what do we mean by
this?
Mass is a very simple idea. It just
means
a lot a lot of people.
Okay? Very simple idea.
Second idea, organization means that
there's a hierarchy in place that allows
the empire to organize its people in a
way that most benefits the empire.
So, for example, the empire can field
large armies.
And the idea of strategic depth is that
the empire can actually afford to lose
a lot of battles
and still continue to fight.
So, think about when Alexander invaded
Persia.
He had already defeated the Persians at
the Battle of Issus,
but Darius was able to go deeper into
his empire and assemble another large
army for the Battle of Gaugamela, okay?
And Darius could have
could have When he lost that battle, he
could have also built a third army, but
ultimately he was assassinated by his by
his generals.
On the other hand, Alexander the
Macedonian, he could not have afford to
lose one battle.
All right? If you think about the World
War II,
Japan had had already conquered China's
entire eastern seaboard,
but the Kuomintang under Chiang Kai-shek
refused to surrender. And he didn't have
to surrender because he could continue
to go in there, right? He first went
into Chongqing and then Chengdu. And if
he had to, he would have gone to Kunming
as well. Okay? So, that's the idea of
strategic depth.
Also, um remember in the history of
Rome, Hannibal had won every single
battle on the Italian peninsula. He had
destroyed all Roman armies. But because
of the idea of death, Rome did not have
to surrender. And Rome only won one
battle against Hannibal in its in its
history, but that battle was the only
battle that really mattered. It was a
battle of Zama.
Uh between Scipio Africanus, the Roman
general, and Hannibal. And Hannibal lost
that battle, and so therefore Carthage
lost the Second Punic War, okay? That's
the idea of death. That's the three
major advantages of empire. If you are a
borderland, you have none of these
advantages, okay? But you have three
other advantages that compensate
for your weakness, okay? The first is
the idea of energy.
So, you have fewer people, but they're
more energetic. They're more ambitious.
They're stronger. They're more
aggressive overall.
Second, uh you don't have
um
you don't have organization, okay? But
you have openness.
And the idea here is
you are open to new ideas, and you can
change a society
at will.
And the reason why is we said this when
when we talked about the Yamnaya, okay?
It's a very important principle that
drives innovation. It's called open
cooperative
competition.
That's why the Yamnaya were able to
innovate. That's why the Greeks were
able to innovate.
Open means there's no central authority.
There's no government.
Co- cooperative means that you're
separate,
but you're still learning from each
other.
Competition means you want to be better
than your neighbor.
Okay? And that's true for the Vikings as
as well. And that's how they were able
to develop the ship technology that
enabled them to
pillage across Europe.
Okay, so that's a main advantage
of
the the borderlands, okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Okay. So,
again, the borderlands have no depth.
They can be wiped out by an empire very
quickly. That's why the borderlands are
opportunistic.
This is a very important idea. It's
It basically means the borderlands have
to be strategic in picking their fights.
If you are bigger than me and stronger
than me, I'll be your friend.
Right? But if you're weaker than me,
then I will steal from you.
The idea here is opportunistic. You're
shameless
in taking advantage of those who you
can.
Okay? Does that make sense? So, these
are the three major advantages of the
borderlands, and I want you to remember
this idea because it will repeat itself
over and over.
All right. So, let me
very quickly explain
the idea of energy
and mass.
And for this,
let's do a thought experiment, okay?
Let's pretend
that you are 16 year old
in
Scandinavia in about 800.
Okay? That's when the Viking Age begins.
By By By 816, what have you learned?
What have you mastered? Well, you your
family are basically independent farmers
who will engage in trade in order to
supplement
their income, okay? So, this is what you
can do.
You can
um
uh basically work the farm.
Work the farm basically means you know
how to grow your own food. You know how
to cook your own food. It means you know
how to take care of animals. If a cow is
about to give birth to a calf, you know
how to do so.
Okay? You know how to, um, save the life
of a horse.
You know how to speak with a horse.
Okay? You also engage in,
uh,
sea trade, okay?
And the idea here is
is that you know how to cut wood and
from the wood build a boat.
And you know how to read the stars
and sail
across Europe.
Okay?
Also, you're a good fighter.
You're able to wield an axe as a weapon.
You're able to use a sword as a weapon.
You're able to shoot an arrow, okay?
If I dropped you anywhere in
Scandinavia,
you're able to find your way home.
You'll be You'll be able to fight
wolves. You'll You'll be able to feed
yourself in the forest and you'll be
able to find yourself home.
Okay? If I put you anywhere in the
European world, you'll know how to
navigate yourself as to find yourself
home.
Okay? And so, this builds the idea that
the Vikings at age 16, they're extremely
worldly people.
Okay? They're strong.
When I mean worldly, I don't mean
cosmopolitan.
What I mean is they have street smarts,
okay?
They're very strong and they're very
resilient.
All right? That's what a Viking teenager
looks like.
Now, let's come back to China in the
present day.
And what do you guys do? What are you
guys able to do? Two things, okay?
Memorize
useless facts.
Do stupid tests.
Okay?
I'm sorry to tell you the truth, but
this is the truth, all right? You
throughout your education in China
have learned exactly two things.
Memorize useless facts and do stupid
tests.
All right?
And the reason why China is like this,
the way the the way that
the reason why most mass societies are
like this is
they want to reduce your energy, right?
They want to be able to control you.
They want you to fit into a larger
society.
Does that make sense? So, you now you
can see
the difference between
um an an energetic society like the
Vikings and a mass society like China.
Okay?
Um
I am I'm I'll be very serious with you.
I have three young kids. My oldest is
seven, my second one is almost four, my
youngest is only one.
As you know, um I received a very good
education. I was at Yale College
for my undergraduate.
Um and I've spent the past 20, 30 years
thinking deeply about education.
And I'll be very honest with you.
If I had a choice whether to send my
child to Yale
or to Viking School
I would send my kid to Viking School.
Because I want my child to be worldly,
strong, and resilient.
Okay?
All right?
And I yeah, I'm not joking, guys. If
there If there were If there was such a
thing as a Viking school where you learn
to be a Viking, I would send my kids to
that school. Unfortunately,
um there isn't. Okay, let's talk about
let's talk about the idea of
opportunistic.
So, the question that scholars have
debated for a long time is, why did the
Viking Age start? What prompted the
beginning of a Viking Age?
Why did the Vikings go attack these
monasteries?
And there are different theories.
Okay, the most popular theory is that as
Charlemagne and his Holy Roman Empire
um expanded, it threatened Scandinavia.
And so, the Vikings had to come out and
challenge him, okay? That's the most
popular
historical understanding.
And then there are some other theories,
for example, population growth, climate
change, internal conflict within
Scandinavia.
Today, I want to I want to explain a
different theory to you, which is just
that the Vikings were opportunistic. An
opportunity arose that didn't exist
before, and they took advantage of it.
Okay?
The opportunity are monasteries.
After the collapse of the Roman Empire,
everyone believes that Europe became a
lot poorer.
Okay? And that's a historical
understanding. But if you think about
it, what really happened is that wealth
became much more distributed.
Okay? During the time of empire, all
wealth was being channeled into certain
centers.
But we we don't have an empire, then
farmers can keep their keep their wealth
for themselves.
So, after the collapse of the Roman
Empire, wealth was much more distributed
distributed.
But as these kingdoms start to arise
under uh Charlemagne,
then
wealth became much more concentrated.
Okay?
So, these monasteries, they are
universities, they're places of worship
and of learning, but much more
importantly, they are places where
wealth is concentrated.
Okay?
Concentration of wealth.
These monasteries, like modern day
universities, are extremely wealthy.
Okay? The first reason why they're
wealthy is their banks.
So, the nobility was actually storing
their surplus wealth, meaning silver and
gold, in these monasteries. These
monasteries were considered to be
protected by divine power. Right? No one
would dare steal from a monastery. Monks
are extremely trustworthy.
So, these monasteries had a lot of gold
and silver stored and hidden within
their premises.
Not only that, but the monasteries were
uh land owners.
So,
they controlled up to 20% of local land.
And of course, what they would do is
they would take this land and lease it
out to
farmers. And they made a lot of money
that way.
Um
they themselves engage in their own
businesses. For example,
um they had their own breweries. Okay?
They could make and sell alcohol and
beer to locals.
Also, as you can imagine, because these
are religious centers, the locals would
invest heavily in them. Okay? The locals
would
uh give them treasures.
And as you can imagine, because there
was this concentration of wealth, and
because monasteries were not protected,
because they were considered protected
by God, they made perfect places
to pillage.
Right? Vikings knew about these places,
and so these places were perfect to
pillage. And that's what we started the
Viking Age, the fact that wealth was not
being concentrated,
whereas before it wasn't.
All right? So, minor stories.
Then you had the idea of armored
knights.
So, the main military
innovation um in Europe at this time
were these tanks called armored knights.
And they were fantastic in battle.
That's how Charlemagne was able to build
the Holy Roman Empire.
Okay? But you think about it, armored
knights do not like water. They will
drown in water.
And so, these rivers were completely
unprotected.
And the Vikings had these long ships
that were perfect for for river
navigation.
Okay? So, that's that's another
opportunity that presented itself.
The armored knights would give rise to
the idea of feudalism.
Feudalism just basically means
that these armored knights became land
owner land owning
nobles that took advantage of farmers.
So, in order to get these knights to
fight uh for them, kings would give them
land grants.
These knights would take this land and
rent it to farmers. Over time, as we
know, farmers will incur a lot of debt.
Which meant which means that they will
not become slaves to these nobles. And
this is the idea of feudalism.
Okay?
Um
And what this means is that by the time
the Viking the Vikings attacked,
Europe was becoming a very hierarchical
society. The thing about hierarchies is
they don't like to change.
So, one question historians had is,
well,
why didn't the Europeans adapt
themselves to these Viking raids?
Some did, okay? But most didn't. And the
reason why is if you change your
military tactic in order to respond to
Viking threat, you have to change your
hierarchy. You have to change your
cultural hierarchy.
Remember when we we did the Greeks, we
learned that depending on your society,
the structure of your society, you had a
different military, okay? So you were a
navy, like Athens, you were a democracy.
If you had a cavalry, like the
Macedonians, you were a monarchy.
If you had hoplites, like the Spartans,
you were an oligarchy. Okay? So the
structure of your military de-
determined the structure of your
political system.
So the Europeans purposely did not
respond to Viking threat because they
wanted to maintain their feudal system.
Okay? And of course this is a this is a
very general statement. A lot did
respond to Viking threat,
but overall they did not respond to
Viking threat with the same emergency or
sense sense of anxiety
um that they should have.
The Viking Age came to an end
when the Vikings amassed enough wealth
to align themselves with the European
nobility.
Okay? So the idea here is if you're a
bandit and you steal a lot of money,
what do what do you want to do? You want
to become an aristocrat, because that's
the best way to protect your wealth,
right? Once you're an aristocrat, you
your wealth becomes legitimate.
So the Vikings
um once they amassed enough wealth, the
Europeans start to intermarry with them.
And the Vikings in turn became
Christians because that was the best way
to assimilate.
And as Christians, they would convert
their own followers and their own people
as well.
Remember, the spread of religion is
usually a top-down process where you
first convert the convert the elite who
then convert the people. It is not a
bottom-up process, okay?
And also, the Vikings provided military
um protection and support to the
European powers.
Okay, and that's what ended the Viking
Age. Vikings were so successful that
they were eventually co-opted into the
European nobility.
Okay?
So,
um
um as I mentioned,
the Vikings, their culture would heavily
influence
um four new civilizations that we'll
discuss later on this semester. And they
are the British,
the English,
the French, the Germans, and the
Russians.
Okay? And so, what I would what I would
do next class
is
show you
why Viking culture is so influential.
Okay?
And to be prepare for next class, what
what I want to do is
give you a preview
of how the Viking worldview is very
different
from other worldviews, okay?
So, um
there's a pre-modern
understanding of the world and there's a
modern understanding of the world.
Okay. So, in the modern understanding of
the world, in the world we live in
today,
the community
is distinct from the individual.
Okay?
The individual can be outside the
community.
Okay? That's why even though you are
Chinese, you're still able to go to
America.
Because you're you as an individual can
be separated from your community.
And often in the modern world, we
believe that the community and
individual are in conflict with each
other. So, for example, if you are a
woman, historically you have been
oppressed by your community.
If you are a homosexual, the same is
true.
If you are a minority, you're often
oppressed. Okay? And that's And that's
what justifies the idea of a
nation-state.
The nation-state
is a entity that protects the rights of
all individuals against the community.
Okay? So, that's a modern conception of
the individual.
And we'll go into this later on in the
semester towards the end, because it's a
very important concept. But first, I
want to introduce it to you, okay?
Now, historically,
most cultures
have not believed this.
Okay?
Most cultures have believed that the
individual
can only exist
within the community.
Okay?
The community is that which gives you
history, tradition,
and a worldview, a religion, a
mythology. And it's your interpretation
of these things that allow for your
individuality.
But you cannot exist outside this
tradition.
Okay? That's why
um most cultures, the worst punishment
inflicted on the individual was not
execution. It was actually banishment.
If you killed someone, we didn't kill
you, we banished you from the community
because that was considered the worst
possible punishment
to a person.
You cease to be an individual, you cease
to be alive if you're removed from the
community that gives you nourishment.
Okay?
Now,
but within this tradition, within this
within this understanding, there are
different ways you can conceptualize the
idea of the community and the
individual, okay?
So, for example, let's look at the
Greeks.
The Greeks,
sorry. Um let me let me let me do this.
The Greeks
believe that the community
was
a was the polis, okay?
The polis. And that's where where we get
the word politics from.
The polis is a place where people gather
in order to discuss
the political spheres of the community.
Okay? That's what community was. It was
where people came together to discuss
politics.
And as a result, the individual
is someone who
stands out.
Okay? That's why we have the concept
arete and eudaimonia.
In this community,
you are an individual, you are the best
individual if you can speak the best, if
you can argue the best,
if you can stand out.
Okay? So, the prime purpose of Greek
life was to stand out so that you could
achieve eudaimonia, human flourishing,
as well as achieve arete, human
excellence.
That is the
um Greek understanding.
Then you have the Romans.
The Romans define community as
tradition and history.
And place.
As long as you are in Rome
and you believe in Roman history and
practice Roman tradition, then you are a
Roman citizen.
Okay?
Doesn't matter where you come from, as
long as you're in Rome and you practice
Roman traditions,
then you are a Roman.
That's why for Romans, what's important
is for the individual to be pious.
Right? Individual is a pious person.
Someone who is loyal
to to to this to
Sorry. Someone who is loyal to the
traditions
of Rome and who
extends the traditions of Rome through
conquest.
That's why everyone wanted to be a
general like Julius Caesar.
To win glory for Rome. And that's how
you show piety to Rome.
Okay?
So, we did the Greeks and the Romans.
Um now, the Vikings
are very different.
The Vikings are very different people.
For them, community
and the individual
are very different. The community is a
collection of stories.
All right? The community
are stories
that are told
over and over
by the people inside the community.
And as such, the individual has
responsibility to
add to the story.
How do you add to a story? Through
exploration.
Through adventure.
Through personal courage.
That's why the Vikings
went off to settle Iceland and
Greenland.
That's why they pillage these
monasteries in the south. That's why
they went to the east and found
settlements like Kiev and Novgorod and
traded with the wider world because they
were trying to add to the larger stories
of the Viking community.
And that's And that's what's important
for them, to be remembered
by the community
through
adventure and exploration.
Okay? It's a very different concept.
And this is what I will explain
next class.
How the entire culture revolved
around this understanding of the
community and the individual.
Right?
The last thing I will say is what's
really interesting uh for us is remember
that these three different cultures
are extremely different, right? They
have a very different approach to the
world. But they all come from the same
cultural origin, which is the
Proto-Indo-European
culture, right?
What's interesting is that as they came
into Europe
and they settled down in different
geographic locations and interacted with
different people, they adapted their
culture accordingly.
So, the story of
human history is always one of
innovation, change, and resilience.
Okay?
All right. Great. Any questions before I
conclude the class?
Was there anything you you were not
you're not clear about?
Okay.
So, the idea of intermarriage, okay?
What is the idea of intermarriage?
Okay.
So,
what's really hard for us to understand
is that for most of human history,
we didn't have a concept of race,
culture, ethnicity,
and borders,
and states, okay? These are all modern
concepts that we go that we use to apply
to history.
They're not very useful.
So, what I mean by that is the Vikings
didn't see themselves as a distinct
culture.
They didn't think we're Vikings, we are
not Greeks, we're not
Germans. No one saw themselves that way.
The Germans
broke the the
the sorry, the Vikings,
their main political unit was the
village,
or the tribe, right?
And the way they fought wars is these
tribes would join into temporary
confederations.
But these confederations were extremely
fluid. So, if you're a tribe and you
want you want to switch alliances, you
could do so, and no one could stop you.
Okay?
So, the very idea of identity was
extremely fluid. And what they
understood was in order to survive in
the world, you have to build alliances.
That means you build alliances with
other Vikings, but if you could, you
could you also wanted to build alliances
with the European nobility because they
have far more wealth, technology, and
resources than you do, okay? So, when
the opportunity presented itself for
them to intermarry into um
these um your into European nobility,
then they did so.
Okay?
So, for example,
the Byzantines
the Byzantine Empire
was
as we discussed, a walled empire. So, it
was impossible to invade and conquer,
okay? The Europeans the Vikings couldn't
really conquer the Byzantine Empire.
But, at the same time, because they were
closed in, the Byzantines couldn't
really
protect their empire.
So, the only way they could protect
their empire was not through the
military, but through diplomacy, through
bribery, through intermarriages.
Okay?
So, the Vikings in Kiev
the Byzantines made an offer.
We will let you guys marry into the
empire, okay? Basically, by having their
ruler marry a princess.
But, on the condition, of course, that
you now serve the empire and
that you uh convert to Christianity,
Orthodox Christianity.
Right? And as you can see, this makes
sense for everyone. The Byzantines have
now have uh more soldiers
who are proven
and who have their own territory, and
the nobility in Kiev, like basically the
prince, he now has legitimacy, right?
Because he's also fighting against the
other Vikings in the area.
Okay? Does that make sense?
And And that's the idea of of
intermarriage, to form a political
alliance that benefits you.
Okay? And And ultimately, if you are a
ruler prince, you're always looking to
intermarry as much as possible.
Right? That's why these kings had so
many wives. These wives represented
different political alliances. It wasn't
because
he was really horny and he loved sex. It
was because as a prince, as a king, you
have to have different alliances.
And the best way to form alliance was
through intermarriage.
And but if you if you marry someone, you
must also marry into her faith, okay?
That was a precondition.
And that's why uh the Vikings in Kiev
would convert to Christianity.
The king converted and then the king
would make his followers convert. But
it's a process that that would take
generations, okay? These things are very
slow because I keep as I keep on saying
in this class, mar- uh culture is
persistent.
Right?
Do
Do you Do you understand? Great. Great
question, okay? Any more questions?
Yep.
Okay. So, the question then is how
like were these pre-modern cultures,
these pagan culture, uh tolerant? How
did it perceive gays and minorities?
Well, okay. Um
uh this is a propaganda from the
nation-state, okay? This This is what
you're taught today, that we are a much
uh higher civilization because we're
much more tolerant towards minorities.
And the truth of the matter is, again,
when you live in a culture which doesn't
really have
boundaries and borders, you're a pretty
open person.
So, in the pagan culture,
there just isn't the idea of
homosexuality.
Men had sex with with each other all the
time and no one cared.
Okay? And women
had fewer rights, but in the Viking
culture, women had status. Okay? Often
because they were they practiced magic.
Okay? In their culture, men weren't
allowed to practice magic. Women
practiced magic.
And you can imagine that would give
women tremendous status.
Okay? So, the idea the the idea that we
have that community suppressed the
individual is something that we believe.
We have faith in it, but it just is not
historically true. Okay?
Also, remember there's a fluidity within
these communities. So, it's perfectly
possible for you to get up with your
family and move somewhere else. No one
can stop you.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So,
the pre-modern world
was much more tolerant than the world we
live in today, mainly because we did not
categorize people back then.
Okay? So, one thing that we will learn
um
uh later on this semester is that the
the very idea of race and racism is a
new modern concept that didn't exist
before. We only have this because of the
idea of imperialism.
Right? When you go and conquer other
people, you need to justify it somehow.
And the best way to do it is through
racism because they are an inferior race
and therefore we have come to civilize
them.
Okay? But this is only in the past 20
years.
And before we didn't have a concept of
race.
All right. Great question. Any more
questions?
Um
so, like what you mentioned, within
society was like low
identity like fluid.
Fluid. Yep.
Um
but the worst punishment is like
banishing people from the society. So,
how about like
within society like Vikings where like
identity like not seen in
What is their worst punishment?
Okay. Uh the Vikings?
Okay. Um the Vikings, their worst
punishment is banishment as well. So, if
you So, for example, if you killed
someone, you'd be banished, okay? Um
the actual punishment would be
determined by a community discussion.
But it was usually banishment or exile
for a number of years.
So, in Athens, um you would be banished
for at most 10 years. That was That was
considered like the most grievous If you
commit the most grievous crime,
um then the worst punishment would be
banishment for like 10 years.
Okay? Because the understanding was
that
um the worst thing that could happen to
you is banishment. Because again, the
individual is part of the community.
You uh were nourished by the community.
Without the community, you were a
nobody. You were basically a ghost or a
zombie.
Okay?
So, those people who get banished still
come back after 10 years?
Yes.
Yes, they always come back. Yes. So, the
Athenians banished a lot of people,
okay? And they always came back.
And
if if if they if they're banished,
they're always thinking about coming
back. Because again,
there was no idea of the individual
existing outside the community. You were
the community.
And if you came into a new community,
then people just just assume that you
are a bad person.
And you were ostracized because where's
your community, man? Right? Because so,
in the ancient world, the first question
they would always ask you is not what is
your name, but where are you from?
Right? What is your community?
Because that's what mattered. Not what
is your name.
Like what do you like? Who are you? It's
always like where are you from? From
what family, from what community, from
what clan, what tribe are you from? Then
we know how to interact with you.
Okay?
Great. Great.
Any more questions?
Great. Okay. So, next class, we will do
the cultural system, the cultural
worldview of the Vikings, okay? We'll
take this We'll We'll take the idea of
community and individual and expand it,
okay?
Okay.